yes I do a daily vlog so I'm documenting
my entire life forever if I actually
from where I started go on to buy a four
billion dollar sports organization and I
documented the entire journey my words
are motivating and I'm good at that but
the reason I knew dailyvee and the
reason I'm documenting so much is if I
can put out a body of work 40 years from
now that showed the process of a young
man that put in the work had the vision
did it the right way
try to help people along the way because
he was trying to build the biggest
building in town by building it not by
tearing everybody else's buildings down
and then I actually accomplished it well
that becomes a real a real a real great
American dream story that becomes a
movie that becomes legacy that becomes
all-time special and I'm not going to
become a billionaire overnight like
sucks or like Sokka or like Travis but
I'm gonna get there as a tortoise which
is going to confuse everybody because I
have a hares costume